all right let's talk about uh where this
could potentially go then instead of the
world falling apart it could be gutted
trump reportedly plans to purge the deep
state if he wins next election will use
executive order to strip employment
protections that's about it they're
saying up to 50 000 employees could be
fired uh i'm voting for trump that's it
that's all
you you you say that to me good sir and
i'm like okay i'll vote for you
there's a lot trump could do wrong at
this point i'd still vote come on baby
take it back i won't hit you again come
on no way he said he was gonna do it the
first time not like this trump actually
did implement executive order schedule f
and then biden reversed it so trump
began the process of trying to fire
these guys these these bureaucrat
administrative state people have have
protections but i'll tell you this it
doesn't matter
joe biden is spitting on us and beating
us over the head and my worst case
scenario is like this guy's promising to
do better it's already bad plus under
trump the economy was good i'll take it
what else what about your desantis push
see that's what i was saying i said i
don't think desantis would fire
everybody like trump would and then all
of a sudden we get a report that trump
wants to fire everybody there we go do
you think trump's listening to you do
you think that's what the that's what
happened yeah i said trump fire
everybody and then trump was like i
think i'm going to fire everybody yeah
what if the sansa said he's going to
fire everybody as well would you vote
for him
well maybe the thing is
that is big
and if desantis said he was going to go
in and fire everybody the exact same way
that's a huge advantage
i don't know though i think trump's got
a bone to pick right i think what really
makes me believe trump would do it is he
wants revenge
that's it desantis would probably try to
negotiate and simmer things down and
then get taken advantage of because
that's what trump tried doing he's like
i'm gonna drain the swamp he gets in and
says okay okay we'll we'll bring bolton
and fine
got knifed in the back for that one
now i think trump
they they really really went after him i
think he wants revenge for russiagate
so
it's that it is his anger over
russiagate and being impeached for
ukraine gate where i think he's going to
go and it should be like you're fired
you're fired you're fired
rhonda sanders doesn't need revenge but
then what after like if he fires
everyone is going to be trusted like can
we can we believe that he's going to
install well what kind of matters after
that because that's what i was going to
say do you really want a guy who's angry
and wants revenge as president united
yes i don't mind anymore but like if he
cleans house in the first year
what happens after that how do we know
that he has less government yeah but
like how do we know he's not going to be
advised we'll just just let this guy
come in and then it's kind of all going
to go back like how do we know that he's
going to be able to reinstall something
because i think rock bottom exists
and i think what we've looked at with
the uniparty over the past several
decades is
so far down we've hit mantle
no rock bottom would be
like fallout we don't that's fallout
like the fallout universe the video game
after it's like post nuclear no i'm i'm
talking about
with with the corruption of our
government when marjorie taylor green
told us that there's like two people
sitting in the house and then they're
just like yay passed next bill
what was that
is that a yes whatever passed did you
know that that's what they do
congress doesn't even go in to vote
it is so broken at this point okay
you're fired get rid of all of it and
then it's like but but but then we'll
have no government i'm like
okay
you have not you have not made a
negative point yet that's a net positive
in my opinion considering how bad it's
been
now there's there's the potential that
donald trump appoints a bunch of
authoritarian fascists it's not going to
happen either donald trump was going to
bring in people like peter navarro and
cash patel who we've already seen who
are actually pretty good and so it's
like okay he guts
they're saying that they don't have to
gut 50 000 people just enough to where
people stop
being corrupt because they know they'll
get purged it'll straighten things out
all right well i'll take whatever i can
get the system's already broken right
someone already stole my tv
i don't got a tv anymore donald trump
says
we're going to go in and we're going to
we're going to arrest all these people
and get them out of there and we're
going to deal with the police department
like oh whatever
my stuff's all gone do it do something
i think the system's always been kind of
janky like put together by duct tape and
string and then the american
constitution was pretty cool and it
makes it run like the engine is turning
everything's okay it's pumping out a lot
of carbon but you know it's functioning
even though it's held together by duct
tape and if you don't constantly keep
patching it up it's just gonna break and
then fall on the ground so we're in that
stage of like why is it shaking so fast
i don't know i don't wanna touch it i'm
gonna get killed if i get near it no
it's we got to do something about this
you know maybe maybe the transmission is
a little bit old on this old rickety
country and you got to take it apart
clean it out and reconstruct it you know
what i mean just put it back in order to
do that you got to stop the machine for
a little while and trying everybody
would be fantastic isn't that what the
work think that this country needs to
just be broken apart and start again no
they think you need to take the
transmission out shout out to a million
pieces and then try and put some and
build a new one or put nothing in place
they think this machine is producing
carbon it needs to be pulled out and
then we'll be great and you're like you
need the machine
so we have a machine that works works
really really well it's a brilliant
system of government we just need to get
rid of the gunk that's stuck in it you
know what i mean just pull it out and
throw in the trash they want to just
shatter the machine
they have no replacement i i what i see
is that trump another trump
term
brings this whole thing that we've been
talking about today
ten levels further you're getting closer
to civil war
much much closer
they've already written articles saying
ron desantis is worse than trump
numerous they will of course they will
so if the argument is that trump winning
escalates it
well they're claiming rhonda sentences
worse than trump so wouldn't that
escalate one article doesn't mean they
all believe it's not one article
numerous articles from numerous
personalities all coming out in lockstep
knowing over the past several months
they saying ron desantis is even worse
than trump ron desantis is he's got the
the sly slick tongue which makes him
even more dangerous
like they said trump was worse than
hitler how many times
if that's the escalation they have trump
is bad they're trying to claim to send
his worse and they've been doing it for
months
if if this hennis wins
it's the same thing it's it's it's not
changing we need we need to just have
someone get in and fire these people and
shut it down
that's not that's not good there's no
there's no
so what's the alternative
let the corrupt gut the machine and sink
the ship term limits for administrative
staff and congress people
uh convention of states but perhaps yes
that's what they're trying to do
convention of states amendment for term
limits on the deep state i i just i
don't see how any of these things stop
the escalation a convention of states
would be the same thing as trump getting
elected if we could get the governors
together and actually be able to convene
on a regular basis enough of us
government governance we could take
control and solve a lot of issues i
think i think it's mostly a cultural
thing anyways like we all know politics
is downstream of culture it won't change
until the culture changes the culture it
can't be changed because there's two
distinct
fortified cultures sure but this is the
first time in history that's been the
case
well i mean typically throughout history
when you have two distinct world views
they don't just come together and shake
hands sure they
wipe the other side out so right now we
have one culture that thinks children
should get sex change surgery and one
side that thinks they shouldn't
i think i don't think there's not really
a compromise there you have one side
that thinks there should be abortion
post viability elective abortion post
viability and one side that doesn't and
there's no compromise
there's that's it there's none
i don't i don't see how you convince
when when right now uh you've got
twitter and reddit saying you can't call
people groomers and they're actually
you've actually people grooming children
you've got a government administration
official saying we should give sex
change surgery to children
dude but they call it affirmations guys
you know i agree with you and all of
this right you know that
my concern is again just speaking as an
outsider i don't comment on american
politics in the sense that i don't live
here i don't pay taxes here it's your
country you deal with with it what you
want
but the conversation i'm hearing here
and with a lot of other people that i
meet
is
like this conversation takes you to a
point of no return
but but there's there's no this is what
i'm hearing right this is why i've been
saying i think civil war is inevitable
because there is no circumstance let me
look do you like the nhs you're from the
uk right yeah do you like it's called
the nhs right it is do you like it
it's hard to it's a hard question to
answer some of it is good some of it's
terrible um do you prefer it like to
what to a private system like we have in
the united states
well i've never experienced the american
system so i don't really know would you
give it up
the nhs like if someone came in and said
we want to abolish it outright would you
agree to that it depends what they put
in
we don't have a plan we want to get rid
of it
no
you wouldn't do that no because i want
to i will come on compromise with me
though like right
how about we get rid of it and then
we'll negotiate on what the
no
let's talk about what you're proposing
instead my proposal is to gut that
system because it's evil and wrong and
replace it with well we'll figure that
out when it comes to it not interested
so it doesn't matter what you're
interested in because we're going to
take it anyway and if you don't listen
we're going to throw a break through
your window that's that's the point
being made right now in the united
states
so when someone comes out and says we
should be able to terminate a viable
baby at eight months if if we want to or
not
there's literally no compromise but that
isn't the law right so there is it is
it isn't and i think seven states and dc
yes and then you have i think was it how
many states have totally banned abortion
at six well there's a lot of block to it
because of the judicial challenges but i
think it's six in total
so we're getting to that point there is
it's no but they're not trying to
mandate that at the federal level you
can live in a state where that isn't the
case right the democrats are trying to
mandate the federal level that you can
abort a baby post a viability up to nine
months yes that's what roe v wade did
for us right he made it up but it but
roe v wade made it so you couldn't ban
abortion pre-viability so uh it was
initially a trimester standard changed
to a viability standard democrats tried
codifying a bill that would allow for
elect
i shouldn't say elective abortion in the
instance of health of the mother up to
nine months but there's there's a trick
there
abortion would mean uh it said post it
said
uh it would allow for abortion of a
viable fetus in the instance of health
of the mother and so the issue there is
if the fetus is viable it can survive
outside the mother why kill it why
legalize the killing of it so they're
like if ma'am if you keep this baby for
another week you'll die so we're gonna
kill the baby
we could deliver it we could do a
c-section no we're going to kill it
so the question is okay maybe maybe
there's a moral argument to why they
wanted to do that they don't have one
they don't give me one i've asked
numerous progressives they don't post it
online why they want to do it and so the
only thing i can say is they're trying
to find a workaround to abort viable
like to kill viable babies
but you have a system in place that
prevents that from being the federal law
right
it could be unless the democrats tried
to make it federal law of course but
you've got to be able to co-exist with
people with whom you disagree in the
same society so the issue is that i'm
saying the disagreements are untenable
there's no compromise there's no
circumstance where well so the
compromise was the overturning of roe v
wade conservatives saying how about your
state can do what you want our state can
do what we want the problem there is
that's one more domino being knocked
over towards a civil war because the
scenario i've presented is what happens
when a man and a woman hook up a woman
gets pregnant and then eight months
later she says you know what this guy is
not right for me i'm gonna go terminate
the baby in texas it would be illegal
for her to do so and i i think it may be
oklahoma where they have or might be
like idaho or something i'm not sure
which one they have they have an
abortion trafficking law meaning if you
aid or traffic in abortion abortions or
tools or or helping someone get an
abortion it's a crime
how will texas deal with the fact that
there's a man saying she kidnapped my
baby at eight months gestation who's
viable and could survive if we just
deliver instead of killing it i'll take
it she can leave and she goes no that
would tie me to you i'm gonna go kill it
instead
what happens
when she flees to colorado for an eight
month elective abortion which she can
get and the father in texas says texas
government please help she's kidnapped
my son
i don't see a solution there
i mean
the way i see it is to try trying to
explain it to pro-choice people would be
imagine a woman kidnapped a baby the day
it was born and then went to a state
where they were going to let her chop
its head off
they'd be like but it's a baby it's like
right right the conservative pro-life
people view it the exact same way when
it's in the womb at eight months versus
when it's out of the women agents
so what do you do
when there's no federal intervention and
the states are forced to decide
how do we save that child from execution
does texas invade colorado or do they
tell the guy sorry she escaped the state
no i think what might happen is colorado
would dem sorry texas would demand
colorado extradite colorado would refuse
then texas would say
we're not going to allow people to cross
you know we're setting up a checkpoint
now to make sure that people can't do
this ever again and then you'd see state
borders popping up and then you'd
probably see vigilantism the dad who
doesn't want a son killed would probably
get a posse together who knows that's
the escalation without federal
intervention and there isn't any anymore
so the compromise was we don't like
abortion but we'll let you do it but now
you have people fleeing to go do it and
it's going to create more tension
that makes sense my point is you're
going to have to work this out man
you just die
that's that's the situation or
see a lot of people talk about civil war
you've never lived through civil war
you don't you don't want it
and that's why the veterans are the ones
who are like please stop right we've
seen conflict and so that that's what my
take on certainly in the uk is like yes
the work have gone crazy
the progressives have gone crazy and
some of the response on the right
bothers me too there's got to be a way
through okay um compromise
what level of child sex change are you
okay with
um
i mean you're picking on a very specific
issue like we can talk about it for half
an hour there's probably some kind of
compromise
for example i employ several people who
have gender dysphoria right if they want
to transition
at the age of 16 with parental consent
do i i don't even know 16 17 18 where
should that line be right well that
we're talking about you know
seven-year-olds no that well children
can't consent well they're transphobic
because this is what they're doing this
is what they're doing in the united
states
and the government came out and told
parents to do it and biden did the same
well see here's the thing right we had a
guy on from the tavistock clinic in the
uk on my show on trigonometry he was
basically a whistleblower saying what
all what was happening in this clinic
well guess what the arguments that
people were making about that exposing
what was happening now the situation is
being wrote back laws are being changed
people are actually getting uh to a
healthier position on that issue and i
think we're making progress right so i
do think
shining a light on some of the stuff
will help over time but if you want an
instant solution yeah you're not going
to get it thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you